BIGGEST INFLUENCE PEDDLING
SCANDALS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
ONE OF HUNTER'S AMERICAN
BUSINESS ASSOCIATES WHO IS
TASKED WITH FACILITATING A DEAL
IN CHINA, TONY BOBULINSKI IS
SOUNDING THE ALARM.
HE SAID THE DEAL IS NOT -- WAS
NOT ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN OR JIM
BIDEN BUT THE BIDEN FAMILY LED
AND OPERATED BY JOE BIDEN AND
BELIEVES THAT JOE AND THE ENTIRE
FAMILY ARE COMPROMISED AND
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE FORMER
BIDEN FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATE,
YOU GUYS NOTONY BOBULINSKI?
I'M GLAD WE'RE INVESTIGATING
HIM.
JOE BIDEN LIED TO THE COUNTRY
AND SAID YOU KNOW FOR A FACT WE
WERE THERE.
HE HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF HUNTER'S
BUSINESS.
>> SEAN, IF YOU'LL HUMOR ME,
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE AT THE
PATRIOT AWARDS AND I'M -- I WAS
IN THE UNITED STATES NAVAL
OFFICER AND MY ENTIRE FAMILY
SERVED THE COUNTRY AND WHAT AN
AMAZING NIGHT THAT FOX NEWS PUTS
ONTO RECOGNIZE ALL THE PRIOR
VETS, FUTURE VETS, POLICE
OFFICERS, AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
I'M JUST FROM MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY, I'D LIKE TO EXTEND A
HOLIDAY THANK YOU TO ALL THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE FOUGHT AND
DEFENDED THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR SAYING
AND FOR YOUR SERVICE AS WELL.
WE HAVE REAL HEROS HERE AND THEY
GIVE US THIS CAMERA EVERY NIGHT
SO WE HAVE A OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
THE STORY THE REST OF THE MEDIA
WON'T AND THAT'S PART OF YOUR
STORY.
YOU MET WITH JOE BIDEN AND
HUNTER BIDEN, ASK JOE BIDEN LIED
WHEN HE SAID HE KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT HUNTER'S BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS.
>> THIS IS TOUGH, OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE FOUR MINUTES AND THIS -- >>
Sean: A LITTLE MORE.
>> A LITTLE MORE.
YOU KNOW, OUT OF RESPECT FOR
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN AND
CONGRESSMAN COMER WORKING REALLY
HARD AND THEIR TEAMS ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD, WALKING AROUND THE
PATRIOT AWORDS TONIGHT I'VE HAD
100 PEOPLE PROBABLY ASK ME IF
JUSTICE IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS.
MY MESSAGE IS JUST BE PATIENT.
I THINK CONGRESSMAN COMER IS
VERY FOCUSED AND CONGRESSMAN
JORDAN IS FOCUSED AND OBVIOUSLY
I'VE PROVIDED EXTENSIVE AMOUNT
OF FACTS TWO YEARS AGO I CAME
OUT PUBLICLY BEFORE THE 2020
ELECTION WITH THE HOPE THAT ALL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD BE
GIVEN THE FACTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGH THE
COLLUSION OF BIG TECH, THE FBI
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, HALF
THE COUNTRY NEVER HEARD ABOUT
THOSE FACTS.
I THINK THAT'S QUICKLY GOING TO
CHANGE STARTING THIS MORNING
WITH THE PRESS CONFERENCE THAT
CONGRESSMAN COMER AND JORDAN HAD
AS WELL AS I WANT TO SHOW DUE
RESPECT TO SENATOR JOHNSON AND
SENATOR GRASSLEY WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING TIRELESSLY ON THIS FOR
YEARS.
THEY'VE BOTH WON THEIR
REELECTION AND THANKFUL FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE
GREAT STUFF.
THE FACTS, SEAN, THE FACTS
MATTER.
WE DON'T HAVE TO SENSATIONALIZE
THIS, THE FACTS MATTER.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW FOR A FACT
BECAUSE YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS
NOTHING ILL LEE.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT IT WITH
JOE AND HUNTER AND YOU WERE IN A
ROOM AND YOU KNOW FOR A FACT ON
THE LAPTOP, IT WAS HUNTER
BIDEN -- ORB JOE BIND.
>> IT'S CRAZY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT TWO YEARS LATER AND
1,000% JOE BIDEN IS THE BIG GUY.
CONGRESSMAN COMER ADDRESSED IT
THIS MORNING THERE'S A TROVE OF
FACTS AND A GOOD NEWS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS THE LAST
VARIETY OF MONTHS AND MULTIPLE
WHISTLE BLOWERS AND THE WHOLE
TROVE OF FACTS CORROBORATING
EVERYTHING I DID AND HAVING
INCREMENTAL INFORMATION FOR IT
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE SHOCK
BID THE FACTS AND HOPEFULLY
JUSTICE IS SERVED.
>> Sean: YOU KNEW HUNTER AND
THE REST OF THE FAMILY.
ANY OF THEM HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE
THAT THEY COULD OFFER THESE
COUNTRIES?
IN EXCHANGE FOR THE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT?
>> THE GOOD NEWS IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO TAKE MY
WORD AND HUNTER BIDEN SAYS HE IS
PUTTING HIS ENTIRE FAMILY LEGACY
ON THE LINE TO DO BUSINESS WITH
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, CFC
AND SAYS THAT IN HIS OWN WORD IN
NUMEROUS TEXT MESSAGES AND ONE
OF THE THINGS PROVIDED TO THE
FBI AND OTHER WEST -L BLOWERS.
DON'T TAKE MY WORD AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS CONGRESSMAN COMER AND
JORDAN AND CORROBORATING ALL
THAT.
1,000 PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS
DOING IT.
>> Sean: CAN I ASK IF YOU MET
WITH ALL THE INVESTOR S?
-- INVESTIGATORS?
>> BOTH CONGRESSMAN JORDAN AND
COMER KNOW I'M MORE THAN WILLING
TO COOPERATE AND SENATOR JOHNSON
AND GRASSLEY AND I'LL MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE TO THEM AROUND
THE CLOCK.
>> Sean: THE ONLY THING THE
BIDENS WERE OFFERING IS WHAT?
THE NAME AND WHAT WERE THE OTHER
COUNTRIES.
YOU'RE TALKING BUSINESS AND HAS
NO EXPERIENCE.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY BE OFFERING
THE TIME OF MONEY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WHAT DID CHINA PRESENT
$1.5 BILLION WITH CHINA.
GOING WITH GOLDMAN SACHS AND
FORMER FIRST LADY OF MOSCOW AND
WHY WERE THEY DOING BUSINESS
WITH THE BIDENS?
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IS IT
GOOD TO BELIEVE WITH THIS AND
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY IS
COMPROMISED WITH JOE BIDEN AS
PRESIDENT.
>> HOPEFULLY THE LAST QUESTION
AND I WANT TO GET TO HERSCHEL
WALKER WHO'S BEEN AN INSPIRATION
TO ME.
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY WAS
COMPROMISED BY THE BIDEN FAMILY
AND I BELIEVE CONGRESSMAN COMER
WILL PROVE THAT AND CONGRESSMAN
JORDAN AND -- THE BIDEN --
SORRY.
>> Sean: I'M GIVING YOU WATER.
EVERYONE CLAP FOR HIM.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I KNOW WE'RE LIVE BUT, YOU
KNOW, THE BIDEN FAMILY WAS DOING
BUSINESS WITH THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY AND DON'T TAKE
MY WORD AND HUNTER BIDEN SAYS
THAT WITH THE FIRST PERSON AND
JOE BIDEN WELL AWARE IN THE
AUDIO RECORDING WHERE HE CALLS
HUNTER TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
NEW YORK TIMES WAS GOING TO
RELEASE AN ARTICLE THAT TALKS
ALL ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: THE FBI HAD THIS
LAPTOP NOW FOREVER AND THEY
DIDN'T DO A THING.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: LAST THING, HERSCHEL
WALKER.
>> YEAH, SO I THINK YOUR
AUDIENCE KNOWS THIS BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING GOING ON IN MY
MIND IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW
IS THE NEXT 20 DAYS, HERSCHEL
WALKER WHO'S A PERSONAL FRIEND
AND HAS BEEN AN INSPIRATION TO
ME SINCE I WAS IN MY YOUNG TEENS
AS AN ATHLETE ENABLED ME TO
DEVELOP THE DISCIPLINE I APPLIED
IN ATHLETICS, THE MILITARY,
COLLEGE AND BUSINESS SO IF IT'S
NOT POLITICAL TO ME, IT'S
PERSONAL.
WHAT AN INSPIRATION HE WAS TO ME
AND HE'S AN INSPIRATION AS A MAN
AND ANYBODY WATCHING THIS,
TEAMHERSCHEL.COM.
HE NEEDS HELP.
>> Sean: HE'S ON TONIGHT.
>> HE NEEDS HELP.
I'M GOING TO GEORGIA AND VOTING
STARTS ON NOVEMBER 28-DECEMBER 6
AND PEOPLE NEED TO COME OUT AND
START VOTING AND SUPPORT HIM.
HE'S A GREAT MAN AND OUR COUNTRY
NEEDS HIM.
AND GEORGIA NEEDS HIM.
>> Sean: TONY, THANKS FOR
STOPPING BY.
TONY BOBULINSKI.
DETAILS ON BRUTAL MURDERS OF
FOUR IDAHO COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
SENATOR JOHNSON REACTS TO HIS
EXCHANGE WITH THE FBI DIRECTOR
RAY ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP
AND